you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
we visit the world's largest wind
turbine testing facility to find out if
the uk can
become a world leader in wind power
the beans that could save up to 4.5
billion litres of water a year in latin
america
and two technologies making air
conditioning more climate friendly
take the top prize at an international
competition but how do they work
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come
boris johnson has said the uk will
become the saudi arabia
of wind but it is a huge task to be as
big a producer of wind energy
as the gulf state is of oil in the last
20 years the contribution of wind power
to the uk's energy mix has risen from
around
320 megawatts in 2001 to more than 24
000 megawatts in 2021 a 73-fold increase
that sounds huge but it's still not
enough
according to the national grid wind
could become
the dominant source of energy in the uk
as we move towards net zero emissions
it can be generated onshore from
turbines anywhere on land
or offshore where the turbines are in
the water in terms of onshore wind look
at how
far behind the uk is compared to
countries including
china and the united states but offshore
the uk benefits from geography and comes
out
on top providing almost a third of the
global offshore wind power
our correspondent lisa holland reports
now from blithe in northumberland
home to the biggest wind turbine testing
facility in the world
the port of blyth used to be europe's
biggest exporter of coal
but has been transformed into a hub
supporting offshore energy
we're heading out to sea from the
northumberland coast to one of the uk's
fast growing number of wind farms
this is how the prime minister is hoping
to deliver on his bold boast
for the uk to be to win what saudi
arabia is to oil
the uk has what many countries don't an
abundance
of wind here in the north sea these
giant
turbines are generating clean renewable
energy
when we talk about reducing emissions
and tackling climate change
this is part of how that's happening
business leaders say the uk has been
slow to pick up on the wider benefits of
wind development
the vast majority of all wind turbine
components are built abroad
so whether that's germany denmark and
spain france etc
and that's from the top of the turbine
to
to sub-sea this is the biggest blade
test facility in the world
at 107 meters you get a sense with me
and the director of the facility walking
beneath it just how long
this prototype is the growth in this
technology has been
so rapid and that we're at capacity
and if we're going to keep the uk at the
cutting edge of this technology then we
need to continually invest
in research infrastructure the
government wants to produce enough wind
to power our homes by 2030 it may be on
track to do that in the uk but not to
generate
enough to export around the world in
large quantities
lisa holland sky news northumberland
well let's head over to our data
dashboard now and you can see the
breakdown of where electricity in great
britain
is coming from today at the moment
56 is coming from fossil fuels
26 from renewable sources including wind
and 18 from nuclear this month we've had
the lowest average minimum temperatures
for april since
1922. that's according to early figures
from the met office and we've seen
increased levels of fossil fuel use
because of it
and you can see a more detailed
breakdown of where that energy is coming
from
including how much is being generated by
wind power on
our website that's at skynews.com
forward slash
climate let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now
climate activists have blocked an
entrance to the fas lane nuclear base in
scotland
members of extinction rebellion and
trident ploughshares
attach themselves to giant plant pots at
the north gate of the base in argyll and
bute
the group say they want a future that's
safe from the threat of nuclear weapons
and environmental disasters co-op has
become the latest supermarket to say
it will stop selling plastic bags for
life the retailer said lots of people
only use the 10 pence bags once before
throwing them away
leading to a rise in plastic use it's
estimated the move will reduce plastic
waste
by 870 million tons every year
and we're being encouraged to let our
gardens go wild plant life wants people
to leave their grass unmowed
and let wild flowers bloom on their
lawns as part of no
mo may the nature charity says it will
help boost the number of daisies
dandelions and other flowers that
provide food for pollinators
in mexico the average person eats 8.6
kilograms of beans
each year but growing them takes
billions of liters
of water and in latin america up to 80
percent of bean yields can be lost
during an early drought
now scientists at the university of
sheffield in collaboration
with experts in mexico have developed a
bean which uses
40 percent less water saving up to
four and a half billion liters a year
i'm joined now by professor alejandra
covarrubias from the plant molecular
biology department
at national autonomous university of
mexico who worked alongside
the university of sheffield's institute
for sustainable
food alejandra thanks very much indeed
for being with us tell us about the new
bean and why it's important
well um this new bean is in progress and
still but it's very very important for
mexico because and
all latin america and even africa
because um
one of the main problems for the
cultivation of this crop
is the is the water you know most of the
of the bean is grown under rain
conditions
so it depends mainly on rain water
so we can have lost eat more
than 70 percent of the of this of this
crop
so it's very very important to have a
crops that are drought tolerant
and that can stand these very
uh severe conditions in the environment
so so it would be very very important to
have this
these kind of beans growing in mexico
and latin america
yeah so there's a double benefit crops
that survive
drought using less water but also
providing food security then for
millions yeah sure
this this uh mexico has a lot of
varieties of beans but because as you
may know
uh is the origin of this of this crop is
in is in mexico in west america
so it has been improved along the
around thousand years so we have many
different kind of
bees that have very different uh
nutritional
characteristics so we may say that beans
are
almost the perfect food because it has
fiber it has carbohydrates it can
it has a lot of protein and so in that
sense
it will have uh as you say uh
two main advantages we will have
beens that can stand low amount of water
in the soil and also bees that are have
a high
values of nutrition yeah how urgent
professor is the need to develop more
climate resistant crops
like these yeah it's very very urgent
the mexico
and africa uh it has a lot of arid
and semi-arid soils so
now the the drought is really
um invading most of the territory of our
country
and of course of africa and many other
territories in south america
so orton is very urgent to have this
kind of crowds
growing in the world actually
professor alejandra covarrubias great to
hear from you thank you
two technologies to make air
conditioning more climate-friendly have
won an international competition worth a
million dollars
the prototypes have five times less
climate impact than standard air
conditioning units
when scaled up such technologies could
prevent 132 gigatonnes of emissions
between now
and 2050 and mitigate over half a degree
of global warming
by the end of the century well joining
me now is dr eradica kosler associate
professor
at the smith school of enterprise and
environment at the university of
oxford reddick thanks very much indeed
for being with us in a
context of climate change how important
are innovations like these
they're incredibly important now we know
that the in terms of air conditioning
the number is that an equivalent of 10
new air conditioners
every second for the next 30 years are
going to enter the global market
so you can imagine how enormous the
energy demand that is going to come from
air conditioning is
and innovations like this and prices
like these are are necessary for us to
be able to bring a step change
in reduction in the amount of energy
that air conditioners are using
and so i think this is an excellent
initiative and i'm delighted to see the
two winners that that have emerged
we're kind of in a trap situation at the
moment aren't we the hotter the climate
gets
the more cold air we need to use and
that then contributes more
to global warming so how do we get out
of that
yes this is indeed a terrible feedback
loop particularly uh
one that haunts air conditioning because
we need air conditioning to to keep us
cooler but that's actually making us
warmer as a planet just as you said now
the ways to get around this are
uh both have have solutions both in the
active
cooling world which is the use of
technologies and in the passive cooling
world which is
when we use non-mechanical and energy or
non-electrified
energy to be able to provide our cooling
needs
so for instance um one big way is to
actually increase the energy efficiency
of air conditioners themselves and
that's that's precisely what this price
does
and other ways to focus on passive
cooling solutions so for instance
using phase change materials for
buildings for windows
increasing the insulation of the built
environment itself
using vegetation as a way to lower
temperatures
and then also to use behaviors right so
to sort of say
what is the set point temperature at
which we put our air conditioner is that
really how cool we need the room to be
or could it be a few degrees warmer and
still provide thermal comfort
do we leave the air conditioner on when
we're outside the room for instance
so using behaviors as a way to moderate
energy demand is also another way in
which to break
that that feedback loop which is which
is quite a difficult one
dr radeko kosler thank you very much
that's it for today's show but you can
get your climate fix over the weekend
with our podcast on this week's episode
we're talking fashion
anna jones is joined by top designers
luxury brands and activists to find out
how we can make sure the most glamorous
of industries doesn't cost the earth
that's on climatecast and it's available
wherever you normally get your podcasts
from
and on our weekly digital show this week
we're finding out the climate impact of
cryptocurrency
and hear the behind-the-scenes story of
how our correspondent tom cheshire
filmed at a secret bitcoin farm in china
that's available on sky news social
channels
our app and website thanks for watching
and we'll see you next week
you